but Elden Ring released and I knew the  second I walked out into Lim grave that  I was about to play something really  special then I looked out at this  beautiful view of lorenia lakes and I  knew that this game was gonna be  something different then I got to the  capital city and my jaw literally  dropped to the floor then I found radon  and the lead up to his boss fight and  knew that this might have been the best  moment I've personally ever had in  gaming then I find out that getting to  the Earth tree isn't the end of the game  but there's even more to explore to the  North and then even more to explore to  the North and then I found this vast  underground area with many different  branching levels and bosses to discover  I'm sure you're getting my point here  the game just kept going you ever wish  you could just erase your memory and  play a game all over again well I had  this feeling four or five different  times when playing Elder ring